Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Aydin. Ich bin hier als Szenarztinthetik und heute für Sie so ständig. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmigespräch führen.
Ja klar, Hauptsache, wir hüft ihr, weil mir geht es gar nicht gut, ja.
Okay. Ich würde so erst ein paar Fragen so Ihrer Person stellen.
Ja, klar.
Wie heißt sie?
Ich heiße Martha Baumgart.
Martha Baumgart. Könnten Sie Ihren Nachnamen bestimieren?
Ne, Baum wie B, A, U, M, wie der Baum, dann G, A, R, T.
Okay. Martha mit TH, oder?
Genau, mit TH, genau.
Frau Baumgart, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 66 Jahre.
66, okay. Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,56 m und ich wiege 84 kg. Ich weiß, dass es zu viel.
Ja, etwas. Frau Baumgart, was schürzt Sie zu uns? Was beschwerden Sie?
Ja, ich habe mit einmal so ganz heftige Schmerzen.
Das hat heute Morgen angefangen.
Eigentlich, ja, ich habe in der Küche ein bisschen aufgeräumt
und habe eine schwere Wasserkiste von einer Seite zur anderen gestellt.
Und mit einmal fing das an, dass ich solche Schmerzen hatte.
Und das hier oben so im Brustbereich unterstrahlte dann so in den Arm rein.
Und tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen hier hoch in den Hals und in den Untergiefer.
Das war mir ganz unheimlich.
Und als ich mich dann hingesetzt habe und ein bisschen ausgeruht habe,
ist das gleich ein bisschen besser geworden.
Aber insgesamt war mir das doch so unheimlich, dass ich gesagt habe,
ich komme jetzt mal zu Ihnen und jetzt hatte ich das Gefühl,
ja, soweit ich mich ein bisschen anstrengen ist,
aber auch wieder ein bisschen schlechter.
Okay, ja, verstehe ich.
Frau Baumgart, wann genau sind diese Schmerzen aufgetreten?
Heute Morgen habe Sie gesagt.
Ja, ich bin aufgestanden und dann habe ich halt erst gefrühstückt
und dann habe ich meine Küche aufgeräumt.
Da habe ich halt so eine schwere Wasserkiste,
ein bisschen eine andere Stelle getragen,
damit ich dahinter sauber machen kann.
Und mit einem fingen das an und das war gar nicht gut.
Und habe ich mich natürlich erst mal hingesetzt.
Und dann hatte ich das Gefühl, das wird wieder ein klein bisschen besser.
Okay, können wir vor eine Stunde sagen?
Ja, ich bin dann ziemlich schnell hier zu Ihnen gekommen.
Okay, ja, verstehe ich.
Und haben Sie Ihre Schmerzen in Ihrem Buchstor, oder?
Ja, genau, ziemlich weit hier oben.
Okay, ziemlich oben, ja.
Und wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskalifon einsbissen,
wobei eins sehr leicht und zehn sehr stark Schmerzen entspricht?
Also vorhin, das war so beängstig, da würde ich schon sagen,
das war bestimmt acht oder sie, doch acht vielleicht, ja.
Aber jetzt ist es zurück ein bisschen besser, ja.
Okay, jetzt ist es besser.
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber ich habe halt so Angst gehabt in dem Augenblick.
Können Sie dies nicht mal etwas genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumpf, drückend?
Nee, dumpf, drückend würde ich die nicht.
Drückend, ja, aber es gelangst so scharf, scharf der Schmerzen eigentlich.
Ja, stechend, stechend und drückend würde ich sagen.
Okay, haben Sie auch Atemnot?
Für den Moment hatte ich das Gefühl, dass ich nicht gut Luft kriege,
aber das ist jetzt wieder weg.
Wieder, okay.
Frau Baumgart, ich muss jetzt unsere Gespräche kurz unterbrechen.
Ich werde Ihre Vital Panameter messen und ein EKG schreiben.
Und ich werde Sie an den Monitor anschließen.
Ah, ja, okay, das verstehe ich, ja.
Ja, okay.
Also das haben wir jetzt gemacht, ne?
Okay, ja, alles läuft und ich lebe noch, ja.
Okay, Sie sind stabil.
Okay, Frau Baumgart, Sie haben gesagt, wenn Sie hinsetzen,
gehen die Schmerzen weg.
Oder, für Sie ist es besser, oder?
Ja, ich habe mich deutlich besser gefühlt, als ich mich dann hingesetzt habe.
Ja, genau.
Okay, okay.
Und vielleicht nach dieser köpelsche Belastung hatten Sie diese starke Schmerzen, oder?
Ja, genau.
Okay, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie früher auch ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Ja, sowas kenne ich eigentlich nicht.
Also ich habe ein bisschen hohe Blutdruck, das weiß ich,
manchmal merkt man das, aber das sind ja ganz andere Beschwerden, als das jetzt, ne?
Okay, bisher haben Sie solche noch nie gehabt?
Nein, das habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Ist es Ihnen übel, Frau Baumgart?
Ne, eigentlich, ne, jetzt nicht.
Also vorhin war mir so ein bisschen flau und ja, ich muss vielleicht sagen,
ich habe mich so ein bisschen ängstlich gefühlt, aber das ist jetzt zum Glück besser, ja.
Ängstlich, okay.
Aber übelst du mir nicht, nein.
Okay.
Ist es Ihnen schwindelig, oder haben Sie Schwarz voll augen?
Ne, das ist es auch nicht, nein.
Okay.
Schüpür Sie, dass Ihr Herz schnell als normal schnitt?
Das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Baumgart, wüssten Sie?
Ja, ein bisschen Husten habe ich, das ist so ein ganz trockener Husten, den habe ich schon seit ein paar Monaten.
Und werde ich irgendwie gar nicht los, obwohl es ja Sommer war, trotzdem muss ich immer so hübschen.
Hm, seit ein paar Monaten, aber nicht neu.
Das ist jetzt nicht neu, nein, nein.
Okay.
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Ihr Beine geschwunden sind?
Ne, die Beine sind eigentlich nicht besonders geschwunden, nein.
Okay.
Sie sind ein bisschen dick, weil ich ein bisschen dick bin, aber sonst nix, nein.
Ja, ja, okay.
Frau Baumgart, haben Sie Fieber?
Oh, habe ich nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht fieberig.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stufros oder Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschweiß habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Können Sie gut schlafen oder brauchen Sie mehrere Kiste und schlafen?
Oder haben Sie irgendeine Schlaffprobleme?
Ja, also ich schlafe nicht so gut, weil ich ziemlich oft Nacht auf die Toilette gehe.
Manchmal dreimal, zweimal, dreimal.
Und deswegen schlafe ich natürlich nicht so gut.
Okay.
Tagsüber mussten Sie auch häufig auf die Toilette gehen oder nur nachts?
Ja, tagsüber fällt mir das nicht so auf, aber nachts ist es halt ein bisschen lästig, ne?
Okay, verstehe ich.
Frau Baumgart, ist Ihr Gericht in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Nee, das ist eigentlich stabil geblieben so, leider.
Ich hätte ja gerne mal ein bisschen abgenommen.
Okay, und ich nehme an, dass Ihr Appetit gut ist, oder?
Ja, der ist ziemlich gut, ja.
Okay.
Ich muss ein bisschen aufpassen, ich habe nämlich Diabetes und da soll man ja nicht so viel essen, ne?
Ja, Sie haben schon sehr krankungen.
Und die Diabetes, deswegen ja, Sie sollten unbedingt auf Ihre Diät achten.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ja, ich habe oft Verstopfung, muss ich sagen.
Brauchen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente dafür?
Nein, dann nehme ich so Hausmittel, dass ich dann getrocknet zu heigen, einweiche oder flaumen
und dass ich vielleicht mal so leinsamen esse oder so und dann klappt das auch wieder.
Okay, sehr gut.
Okay, Frau Baumgart, ich möchte jetzt über Ihre Vorerkrankungen sprechen.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Wuletuchtung und Diabetes haben.
Und irgendwelche andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, in meinem Alter, ne? Ja, klar.
Also seinerzeit, als man das mit dem Diabetes und mit dem hohen Blutdruck festgestellt hat,
hat man dann auch noch festgestellt, dass die Blutfettwerte so ein bisschen erhöht sind.
Da soll ich also auch eigentlich aufpacken.
Ja, genau genommen müsste ich also eigentlich ziemlich Diät essen, aber mache ich halt nicht, ne?
Und dann hat man vor drei Jahren auch festgestellt, dass ich unter Gift leide.
Also nochmal so etwas, was auch unbequem ist.
Okay, vor drei Jahren.
Die andere Krankheit, Blutdruck, Diabetes und Epileptie, sind seit wann?
Das ist schon seit zehn Jahren.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen oder wichtige Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, also ich hatte eine Knieprothese links bekommen, weil ich Atrose habe.
Das ist jetzt acht Jahre her.
Und dann ist mir, auch umnächst, da hatte ich eine Gebärmutter-Senkung
und hatte damit solche Probleme.
Und dann hat man die Gebärmutter vor neun Jahren entfernt.
Okay, vor neun Jahren.
Waren Sie damals auch in den nächsten Jahren?
Ja, ja, ja.
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig Frauenarzt?
Ja, da bin ich ganz tapfer, gehe ich regelmäßig hin.
Und jetzt zuletzt war ich vor einem halben Jahr.
Okay, diese Gebärmutterentfernung ist wegen einer böse Erkrankung oder?
Nein, wegen einer Senkung.
Senkung, okay, okay.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Operationen gehabt?
Nee, das war es eigentlich.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Baumgart, welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ja, also ich nehme Aspirin morgens und abends.
Dann nehme ich Medformin auch morgens und abends.
In welche Dosierung? Aspirin und Medformin?
Aspirin 100 und Medformin 500.
500, okay.
Und was, ne?
Dann nehme ich noch Weisartan 160 gegen den Blutdruck.
160.
Bitte?
Können Sie wiederholen die Dosierung?
160.
Ich meine 160 steht da drauf.
Dann nehme ich morgens eine.
Okay.
Und?
Ja, sonst nehme ich eigentlich nichts.
Ja, ich habe mal so...
Moment.
Geht gerade nicht.
Ich bin wieder da, Entschuldigung.
Kein Problem.
Ja, manchmal habe ich so ein bisschen viel Magensäure gehabt.
Da habe ich dann mal Panto Hexal bekommen.
Das nehme ich aber nicht regelmäßig.
Nicht regelmäßig, okay.
Panto Hexal.
Ich glaube, das ist Panto Hexal 600 heißt das glaube ich.
600, okay.
Okay.
Hab es ihr mitwärtsch Allergien, Frau Baumgart?
Ja, ich habe wirklich zwei wichtige, die man festgestellt hat,
wo ich ein bisschen aufpassen muss.
Das eine ist auf Jod.
Und das andere ist eine Pädizellin Allergie.
Okay.
Wie oisen diese Allergie bei Ihnen?
Ja, ich krieg also so rote Quaddeln.
Okay.
Und Joghreiz, ne?
Frau Baumgart, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Gegen Corona, meins, habe ich drei Impfungen, ja.
Okay.
Und sonst habe ich eigentlich auch, glaube ich, alles, was man so an Kindertrankheiten haben kann,
habe ich mal gehabt.
Okay.
Also die Impfungen mal gehabt, ne?
Okay, Frau Baumgart, rauchen Sie?
Ja, nicht mehr.
Ich rauche jetzt schon zehn Jahre nicht mehr.
Da bin ich sehr stolz drauf.
Und vorher habe ich, ja, viele Jahre,
aber nicht so schrecklich viel geraucht.
Also nicht mal ein Kekchen am Tag, so 15 Zigaretten am Tag habe ich geraucht.
Und wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
War schon eine ganze Weile, das waren über 30 Jahre.
Über 30.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ganz wenig mal.
Ja, malen, die Körer oder, was weiß ich,
wenn es mal etwas zu feiern gibt, ein Glas Sekt, aber eher wenig.
Eher wenig, nicht täglich.
Und Gottes Willen, nein, nein, nur wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt.
Okay.
Frau Baumgart, ich nehme an, dass Sie keine Droge nehmen, oder?
Ich droge? Nein, nein, die nehme ich nur wirklich nicht.
Geh ich Sie fragen, ich stelle mich an alle unsere Patienten,
das ist meine Nussdächerin.
Können Sie Sport treiben?
Noch mal bitte.
Treiben Sie Sport, Frau Baumgart?
Ach, in meinem Alter und bei meinem Gewicht,
ist das mit dem Sport so eine schwierige Sache?
Nein, also wenn alles gut läuft, laufe ich mal mit dem Fahrrad zum Einkaufen,
aber sonst mache ich keinen Sport, nein.
Okay.
Wir kommen gleich zu Ende, Frau Baumgart.
Noah, möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Ach, mein Vater ist tatsächlich hoch betagt,
er lebt immer, lebt noch und er lebt in einem Pflegeheim.
Der ist ganz dement und da haben wir natürlich große Sorgen.
Okay, ja.
Und meine Mutter ist ganz früh gestorben, die ist nur 60 Jahre alt geworden,
die hatte Leberkrebs.
Leberkrebs, okay.
Hat Ihr Vater noch andere Erkrankungen?
Also nicht, dass ich wüsste, ich glaube, da ist er gesund.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Eine Schwester habe ich ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Nein, leider nicht, die hatte vor einem Jahr einen Herzinfarkt.
Okay, das ist mir leid.
Aber sie lebt noch, oder?
Ja, ja, die hat ihnen ganz gut überstanden,
aber das war natürlich ein Schreck.
Okay, natürlich.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwidert seit zwei Jahren.
Verwidert, okay.
Leben Sie allein?
Ja, ja, ich lebe jetzt alleine, die Kinder sind alle groß,
sind alle aus dem Haus.
Okay.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Oh, wir hatten vier Kinder, eine große Familie.
Okay, sehr schön.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Die sind Gott sei Dank alle gesund, ja.
Okay.
Frau Baumgart, sind Sie Rentnerin oder Arbeiterin?
Ich bin Rentnerin, ja, zum Glück, ja.
Okay.
Früher, in welchen Bereichen haben Sie gearbeitet?
Ich war als Schneiderin unterwegs, ja, ich bin Schneiderin.
Schneiderin, okay.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Baumgart, ich glaube, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestartet.
Möchtest du Sie etwas missüffern oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, Sie haben mich so viele Sachen gefragt
und ich habe Ihnen so viel erzählt.
Ich glaube, da ist nichts offen geblieben.
Was ich natürlich jetzt wissen möchte,
woher kann denn diese schrecklichen Schmerzen,
was kann man dagegen machen?
Natürlich ist das etwas Schlimmes, das möchte ich gerne wissen.
Frau Baumgart, ich musste auch noch eine Frage stellen.
Wurde bei Ihnen ein Herzkatheter untersuchen, durchgeführt?
Irgendwann in den letzten Jahren?
Nee, ist noch nie gemacht worden.
Ja, noch nie. Okay, ja.
Frau Baumgart, ich denke, dass Sie einen Herzgefäßprobleme haben
und diese Beschwerden sprechen für ein Herzgefäßproblem,
eine Verrängung vielleicht.
Ich werde Sie jetzt natürlich körperlich untersuchen
und dann ich werde Ihr Herz auch untersuchen.
Ja, nach der Ergebnisse können wir widersprechen.
Aber die Beschwerden sprechen für ein Herzgefäßerkrankung.
Okay, gut, dann warte ich jetzt auf weitere Untersuchungen.
Ja, bitte.
Ich werde gleich Sie untersuchen.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Ich habe keine Frage.
Sie haben keine Fragen.
Herr Dr. Günnessen, das ist aber mal wirklich eine Seltenheit.
Also wenn jemand herzlich beschreibt und Sie haben keine Fragen mehr,
Frau Alin, da haben Sie aber sehr komplett nachgefragt.
Merken Sie schon, ne?
Jetzt denke ich ja.
Ich habe auch die Frage von Herr Günness gewartet.
Ja, ja. Sie nehmen mir das nicht übel, ne Herr Günness?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Alles hat Sie gut gefragt.
Sie hat wirklich, also sehr zielstrebig und sehr präzise gefragt.
Alles war super, ja.
Und Reaktion hat sehr gut gestenkt.
Reaktion.
Ja, also es war richtig super.
Wollen Sie schon gleich weitermachen oder brauchen Sie doch einen Moment?
Gleich ein Minute werde.
Ja, alles gut.
Sofort kontrollieren.
Heute 35 Kollegen.
Ja, aber ja.
Ja.
Höre ich daraus, dass wir in eine strenge Prüfungsphase kommen?
Haben jetzt viele Prüfungen?
Ja.
Aber in den nächsten drei Monaten.
Ja, in den nächsten drei Monaten.
Naja.
Diese Monat keine, aber in der letzten Monat.
Oktober, November, Dezember kommen wir.
Ja.
Ich muss gleich beichten.
Im Oktober bin ich nochmal zehn Tage weg.
Und da bin ich auch so weg, dass ich eigentlich nicht gut abends Zoom machen kann.
Ja, da muss ich dann leider einmal ausfallen lassen.
Okay.
Ein paar Tage. Aber Sie haben ja noch alternative Leute, ne?
Welche Tage?
Ich bin weg vom ersten bis zum elften.
Okay.
Wir können also nächste Woche noch machen.
Und dann können wir in der nächsten Woche,
ich weiß gar nicht, weil ich dann den Dienstag nach Hause komme.
Dann in der Woche drauf, dann ein, genau,
erstes bis 11. Oktober, genau.
Ich glaube, der 11. Dienstag.
Und dann können wir an dem Donnerstag wieder machen.
Okay.
Ich möchte zwei Fragen stellen.
Geht es?
Ja, ne.
Also beim Tiefatmen füllen Sie mehr Schmerzen.
Am Torachsbereich, links Seite.
Glaube wohl. Ich glaube wohl.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Glaube wohl, ja.
Und die anderen, Sie haben zwei Operationen durchgeführt.
Sind die Operationen Komplikationen los durchgeführt?
Ja, da war nichts Besonderes.
Ja.
Danke.
Ja, gerne.
Ich bin bereit.
Ja, wunderbar.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen unsere neue Patientin vorstellen.
Ja, wer ist das denn?
Frau Marta Baumgart ist 66 Jahre alt.
Der Patient ist wie 80 Kilogramm schwer und 1 Meter 65 groß.
Die Patientin.
Die Patientin stellt sich heute bei uns wegen ungefähr seit
einem Stunden bestehende Stärke Schmerzen in Brustkorb vor.
Die Patientin erkennt, dass die Schmerzen durigend und stationt sein
und in den Hals und in den Unterkielfahre ausstrahlen würden.
Und die Patientin hat die Schmerzen in den Unterkielfahre ausgestattet.
Außer den klacktidee Patientin über Engstgefühl, der Bahinaur, der Leihidee Patientin unter Nücturin,
der Taschekartee, die Dusbne, die Nausea, die Burdenferneint, die Zyber-Permonaten, die die Patientin trocken und furschen.
Die restliche vegetative Anamnese sei bis auf Obstipation, die Anforeinheit, die Patientin
HBZ-Sch, eine Tab wegen einer Gonarthrose unterzogen und vor neun Jahren HBZ-Sch einer Historektomie unterzogen.
Die Patientin neime regelmäßig 2 Mal 100 mg Asteroxycylcylsohrem, 2 Mal 400 mg Metformin, einmal 180 mg Weißsartan, ein Ternia, Neimezi, Baibedarf, Pantohexal, 600 mg ein.
Die Patientin sei vollständig geimpft, bei ihr sei im Jod und Penicillin allergieen bekannt, die allergieen oysen sich als exzente.
Die Patientin rauf ist seit 1.Jh, die Patientin HB, für sie hat sich in den nächsten Jahr aufgehört.
Dafür hat sie für sie 3-Jährigen, für sie hat sie eine Sekretin gekriegt.
Sie konsumiert selten Alkohol, drogen Konsum wurde fendenlein. Sie treibt selten Schkort, sie fahrt manchmalt Farad.
Die Familien, Anamnese, Ergab, Demenz, Bayram Fatah und Hepatocelular, Karcinon, Bayram Motta.
Die Patientin HB, eine Schwester, die eine Mucardinfarkt gelitten hat.
Die Patientin sei verliebt, sie hat sie vier Gesunde, sie hat sie von allen, sie ist der Renklerin,
die die Brühe, die die Haberli, die Alkstischen haben.
Was ist die höhere Verlachsdiagnose?
Meine Verlachdiagnose ist Angina pectoris.
Die als Differenzialdiagnose ist eine kommunale Mucardinfarkt.
Herzinsuffizie.
Nicht so hochwarsch, aber vielleicht Pino motorax.
Ja genau.
Ich würde zuerst die Patientin Kölperlisch unterzuholen.
Ich habe schon Vitalpyramide, überprüft.
Und sie warst du auch?
Ja, sie warst du auch.
Ich habe auch eine EKG geschrieben.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich die EKG habe.
Ich habe ein paar Laboren unterzuholen.
Es war Blutbild, Cardiacenzymen,
und Troponen.
Ich habe eine Herzinsuffizie als Ausduschliasen,
eine Möschleis auf Enti pro B, pro BMP.
Ich habe 5.
Worauf gucken Sie im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung
von der allein, von der optischen Untersuchung her?
Worauf schauen Sie da insbesondere?
Ich habe die Inspektion,
die ich beurteilen würde, ob der Patient Atomot hat
oder die Siamese vorliegt.
Ich habe auch beurteilen, ob eine öde vorliegt.
Ich werde auch beurteilen, ob eine öde vorliegt.
Ich werde auch herzoskürzieren,
ob die Erzene regelmäßig sind,
ob eine Testschikarde oder eine Palpitation beurteilen.
Gut, wunderbar.
Eigentlich waren das schon die Sachen, die ich auch erbaut habe.
Was würden Sie nach dem EKG und nach Ihrer Untersuchung
noch ans fortführenden technischen Untersuchung vorschlagen?
Eschokardiografie ist auch hilfreich.
Wir können Herzfunktion beurteilen.
Herzkläpfung können wir auch beurteilen.
Wenn eine Myokalinfarktus vorliegt, können wir die Wandbewegung des Herzbeurteilen.
Eschokardiografie ist sehr wichtig.
Und als nächster Schritt, wenn wir weiter noch Verdacht haben?
Können wir Herzkateter untersuchen,
ein Geogratm büschüren.
Darüber würden Sie die Patienten separat aufklären?
Ja.
Dann bin ich gespannt, was Ihre weiteren Untersuchungen ergeben.
Bisher sieht es so aus, dass Sie noch mal Glück gehabt haben.
Dann halten Sie mich auf dem laufenden, was bei Ihrer Patientin rausgekommen ist.
Können Sie vielleicht zufällig morgen Ihre Prüfung machen?
Seit sieben Monaten warte ich auf einen Termin.
Ich habe immer noch keinen Termin.
Sie sind so gut. Sie könnten sofort loslegen.
Das war eine perfekte Vorstellung.
Sowohl, was die Anamnesenerhebung angeht, als auch die Schöderung.
Ich habe eine winzige Sache.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, sie ist 1,56 groß.
Sie haben daraus 1,65 gemacht.
Das ist bei den 84 kg.
Das ist immerhin relevant, weil das Ungleichgewicht noch etwas mehr verstärkt.
Die ist also schrecklich klein und schrecklich dick.
Das ist das einzige, sonst gibt es überhaupt nichts zu meckern.
Sie haben alles aufgeführt und nicht ausgelassen.
Sie haben das auch sprachlich sehr schön gemacht.
Was man vielleicht noch machen könnte, haben immer wieder gesagt, die Patientin, die Patientin.
Sie natürlich auch.
Sie können zwischendurch mal ein bisschen abwechst, dass Frau Baumgart hat.
Sie können mal zwischendurch den Namen sagen.
Bei ihr war das im Gespräch sehr angenehm.
Sie haben sehr oft mit Namen angesprochen.
Jetzt ist mir das Aufruf bei ihrer Schöderung.
Das ist relativ häufig.
Aber das ist wirklich Kosmetik.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, viel besser kann man das nicht machen.